[Music]
hi I'm Casey Scobie I'm the info cago
city council packs planner hi i'm robin
pagan of the capital city council parks
manager ensign park art gallery society
had already recognized that the current
facility was not adequate for their
collection so it won't be possible to
add other collections to that area so
council will be maintaining the
residence once it's complete and there
will be many options available for
management but we haven't decided which
option we'll be taking at this stage
there's two parts to it a small kitchen
for a cafe or if they decide to have a
full catering facility or would be a
kitchen to cater for that so the
original house and home Steve did have
fruit trees and vegetable gardens with
us and we there will be plans for it to
be reproduced such as the auto mental
vegetable garden that's currently
located beside the house which is
already VSO that's a start
there wouldn't need to be provision to
increase and upgrade the existing car
park the driveway there's no intention
to widen or remove trees in the driveway
I'd be careful that we didn't over
develop the area because it's quite
unique the way it is at present what
would you say you could put a really
cool water fountain and the pot in the
pond that sort of shoots up all the
water in there they'll be quite a quite
cool sculpture that you could add in
there yeah an acquired additional land
for wedding venues or something like
their helicopter bed yeah
[Music]